володимир перлами виписуєте знімати до
або каріння
український партизан тарік петер зовсім
нами не на луганщині і по трапу сповнений
сепаратисти
сама над ним peach особливо у місяці нам
з душа все про російського пропагандиста
грехем філіпс окинути релюхи зараз
чергуванні колишніми перлинами на
проходячи україни лику balloons машині за
зараз молодому розрубали 5 укороті
видно були слух вирізав ігри ж на
животі а холодно та повернув easier ще
правда поки лиж і на одному у ati тани за
баром очевидним і те, й інше знати про
стю шкалу а б в г д так оскол і оперся
через тинь данина паба чорти великі літери
найбільше я їх побачивши я пішов за сміхом
тис і лікарка побачила під пахву фаршу
пас ведмедика ось dota я ніби кипу похмурий
тепер валдемар може читати їжі ви тис
і телевізор і winapi малювати і семиста
я вийшов у карені і пішов у своїми ногами
ти порви 0 до пи один у одному пудру я
гуляючи кельна
цьому годинниковому ведмедику їм он і милу і temiz
цілу красою а часом мантр піти на
еблище німецьким місцям молодому разу
маккой місця веб його випічка
алена у захопили чистої природи про
притягни ж дані знаю німецьку і самості
знаходиться покупкам та їздити на автоматі
кому транспорті без проблем майже
їжі ще не розібралася і я взяті пилю
ви квиток club raj на 2 людей на довгу
дистанцію здається ти їжі, що йшла виходить
тауразі вимагатиме завжди на зв'язку
українських волонтерів на мій учень
нікита допомагає з прикладом перемити
rhodan і фінансово та моральному самі
перли ви такий жовтий це допомагати
меншим за крима дуло чаю почуттю різьблених
акції на petrenko українських дискових
віці прибуває всі вікна Батьківщині так
та слухати чонін ми видав of cable and
там весь корж петаль
там пара буває 3 українські солдати ваш
капур вона не ми їздові спектри мати
ні ще показати саме їм була
хлопці частіше тайському вірші якщо ж кому
ще гірше, а нормально просувати їх
відвідали у не меч і не під balan тільки і
просто на здоров'я владимира і про без
pq батьківщини за блага навик раді не росією
українські акти листя пояснюють
перли подружку не меч і не
спромоглася все шви на хочеш додому
так у магате дзвенить і нижчих планетах
тапу бакшт і
еньші України що так станеться зробити
для країни
хочеться рахунок зуби ти для країни чесно
вкажу чіпом андр у святому винен і
відразу мило шуму ми не можемо вже ти так
саму добре можемо ж як живуть в Європі
ми так само
а ми всі так сама йому сиділа над
дорогами
з приводу валдемара щоки кооперації
змикання до нових протезів на руку
поїздка додому на новий рік
[музика]